To tell women with children
that nobody's gonna love you if you have kids.
Nobody's gonna want you once you've had kids. Bob,
that is some straight fucking bullshit.
There will be a line out the corner of men ready to line up. Diapers,
wipes for what do you need, girl?
What do you need?
I'm not even saying you gotta fuck with those kinds of men,
cause some of them are shady as fuck.
What I'm saying is
don't let some fucking idiot tell you
that nobody's gonna love you cause you have kids.
That is some straight fucking bullshit.
That's why they had a kid with you.
To try to trap you,
to keep you stuck so that then they could use that fucking lying shit.
Ah, ah,
look at young gravy.
Look at there.
Just so many fucking examples.
Don't fucking stay with some asshole cause he's putting you down.
Shut the fuck up! No!